[Music]
welcome to the heavy spoilers show I'm
your host definition and this is the
channel where we explain it so you don't
have to those who've been following Game
of Thrones throughout its eight seasons
will remember that Tywin Lannister at
one point was one of the big bad
villains of the show whilst the
character came to an ironic end that
held huge repercussions over the show
and even had moments that influenced the
final sections of the season actor
Charles dance who portrayed the warlord
recently stated that he has been less
and impressed by the final episode
during an interview with good morning
Britain in which dance was promoting his
upcoming film Godzilla king of the
monsters the actors stated that he found
the finale confusing in the following
clip dance states his dismay over the
finale and admits that he wasn't on
board with the ending yes you were
ruthlessly and somewhat humiliated he
killed off by our son weren't you on the
news after all I've done for the most
extraordinary character gripped by him
when you first got that part did you
ever think it would have that sort of
resonance and have that impact on on you
and your career and and you know the
consciousness of I don't think any of us
did actually you know HBO spend a great
deal of money putting production values
on a television screen that you're more
likely to see in the cinema so for those
reasons you know we just felt the thing
was pretty good but none of us knew that
it was going to take off to be the most
successful television series ever made
which is what it is
what series Charles because I've been at
it and watching ever since the first
episode in fact I win about that I went
and read the books because I didn't want
to wait what did you make of the last
series did you watch much I was confused
yeah I've watched as much as I can
because there are you know characters
like Daenerys that character my
character you know we never met or we
don't need me to kind of press junkets
and things so I wanted to know what was
happening to these people
and I saw how the last series and then
we come to the big last serious and got
to the very end and I thought okay
there's little arias she's going off on
a cruise somewhere what John's gone back
up now yep beyond the wall and then
there's Tyrion who you won the all the
people left alive or sat around the
table so you know what we're gonna do
now shall we have a cup of tea or
something I thought I don't know could
you want a Tyrion to come through and be
the boss okay me personally yes that
would have been a great finish I don't
bloody tales we are out of time we could
talk for hours and hours and hours good
luck with Godzilla
thank you very much your phone Matthew
thank you so much for coming in this
morning as well it always is a treat to
see really pretty pleasure thank you
similar to a lot of fans it's clear that
Charles is not on board with the
divisive ending of the show and he's
echoing many of the faults that we've
seen published online during the last
week since the show aired it's clear
that the actor thought that the logical
conclusion was for Tyrion to gain the
throne and at many points throughout the
show's eight seasons he has seemed like
a front-runner this probably would have
been my second choice after Jon Snow to
get the throne and I don't want to slam
the ending too much as I've done it a
lot already but it seems like they
purposely picked bran just for shock
reasons what I love about this interview
is that he mentions little Arya going
off on a cruise somewhere which is a
hilarious take on her character's
eventual ending he also does a brilliant
Yorkshire accent for Jon Snow going back
up north and that was so bad and the
overall interview is really fun to watch
I'll leave a link to it in the
description below so you can check out
the entire thing as it's definitely
worth watching and again it just kind of
reinforces what many critics have been
saying about the show obviously I'd love
to hear your thoughts on this interview
and the finale as a whole so make sure
that you comment below and let me know
and if you enjoyed this video then
please like it and make sure you check
out my alternate ending video for the
eighth season would you be linked at the
end
this is the channel for people who are
never missing television so if that's
the kind of thing you like you need to
subscribe to definition thanks again for
taking the time to watch this you've
been the best and I'll see you next time
take care peace
[Music]
[Music]